meine güte sind ich habe es ja
absichtlich werden jetzt werden wir
abgesetzt was er furchtbar
[Musik]
nach dem motto bot werden uns jetzt
verschiedene gedichte vorgelesen und wir
müssen herausfinden sind sie geschrieben
von einer künstlichen intelligenz oder
von einem echten menschen es ist
wirklich schwer schlechte nachrichten
zum helden ohne zu weinen
das ist der high court in new york times
echt großartig
toll ich kannte mal jemand der hieß
heiko bott
ich fühlte mich so als sähe ich ihn
selbst sein gewissen graben das ist
jetzt bestimmt eine
sie möchten und sagen maschine aber das
ist kein diese trickreiche stimme die
von irgendwoher uns diese dinger vor
ließen nicht erkennen und ich sage das
ist eine maschine grammatikalisch falsch
ok ich sag es ist ein mensch es ist
wieder der bot der new york times
nicola führt ich habe dich zur königin
ernannt größere gibt es größer als du
reinere gibt es reiner als du schönere
gibt es schöne als du doch du bist die
königin kommt also der text ist ganz
einfach das hat ein mensch gemacht weil
so banal
ja und auch von der logik der gedanken
welche logik ist es eben kein es ist
nicht logisch genug für eine maschine
aha das ist für mich eine gute theorie
ich frag mich pablo neruda haben und er
ruhe
meine güte blumen und gold zugleich
machen reich goldenen rahmen siehst du
erfüllt mit deinem bett sie nur wie
köstlich es ist das von mir aber das ist
aber schwer das ist schon sehr komplex
aber vielleicht ist es schon wieder so
komplex dass doch nicht komplexer
köstlich mit goldenem rahmen das doch
komplex also ich sage das war eine
maschine ganz klar und du ja ich sage
auch es war eine maschine sei das war
gilt maschine habe ich doch gesagt nein
geht es sind ich habe es ja absichtlich
sehr gekränkt weil ich dir ein besseres
gefühl geben wollte
du hast einen punkt ich habe null du
hast 1 meine güte ist das peinlich
jetzt werden wir abgesetzt dass er
furchtbar auf der flucht gezimmert in
einer sommernacht schleier auf der mahle
räumliche nahrung dieses liebe ist eine
maschine so ähnlich und auch das ist ein
mensch zu räumliche nahrung bei diesen
bitte räumliche nahrung gebe ich mich
erst einmal schien als mensch das war
tunnel23 das wort gleich den
beschwingten pfeil und ist es einmal
deinen burgen in tempeln oder ernst
entflogen erschrecken musste ich seine
ein mensch maschine
es war eine davon drosseln ich habe nur
noch nur noch lesen was mich auszeichnet
ist dass sich ein angenehmer gewinner
bin so bescheiden es kann uns allen
passieren dass wir mal danebenliegen es
ist ganz menschlich nicola nimmst nicht
so schwer
bis nächste woche die bevor hinter
tunnel 32 ist das nicht ein kinder
nahmen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]